sono tutti ragazzi
bentornati su di te forse no oggi remo
ha un gioco horror che si chiama berlino
tutto avendo sul tavolo per vedere cosa
se ce l'hai non sappiamo quasi niente di
questo gioco tranne che c'è chi con un
orsacchiotto che è molto inquietante
ma è la prima volta che ci giochiamo non
abbiamo idea di come ti giochi next
diffusa farli quindi siete pronti
mettetevi comodi prendete il corpo e
niente le luci e ritengo subito quindi
spesso il famoso
[Musica]
eppure di tastiere non si sa perché e
mezzanotte
[Musica]
io mi devo spostare diventare a
rispondere pronto a nessuno
so che ci sono le camere di strutture
fan visto o perché una porta non so bene
tutto devo fare lo stato mi piace se
volete vedere giudizio fiori sul canale
e fateci sapere sto bene perché mai
giocato questo gioco che non c'entra ben
poco a entrambe le porte
ma perché continua a parlare questo è il
messaggio che sta facciamo una cosa
crediamoci il suo demo due giorni per
sentirlo ci troviamo le camere di
sicurezza ci sono questa specie di
bambole è una festa di compleanno faraci
sono in favole con il comune per
caricarli la completa ma vorrei rivedere
qualcosa di strano se camere di
sicurezza imposte ciò bagni potete
puntare per uscire l'acqua per jean luna
in questo modo sarà aperto le altre
forte c'è tempo il l'energia sta finendo
diminuendo e 67 per cento potevo fare
l'ho più visto ok il messaggio adesso
civile forte solo se necessari quindi
ora le riapro forse dovevo aspettare che
finisce di parlare per un altro non
ascoltato quasi niente di quello che ha
detto riaperto le porte e riacceso dagli
usci abbiamo visto qualche tutorial
perché altrimenti non capivamo
praticamente io devo controllare queste
sorte di pupazzetti che sono delineati i
mattoni store e stanno cercando di
raggiungermi e non so se vogliono
uccidermi o vogliono scappare
io devo controllare
dove di sicurezza dove trono devo
cercare di conservare più energia
possibile evitare la sta consumando
tutta preparate le porte sono aperte
come tanti ora ha solo 29 per cento di
batteria
se la consuma tutta pensate non posso
più guardare le camere ne aprire o
chiudere le porte e praticamente devo
stare attenta se loro si stanno
avvicinando e chiudere le porte prima
che entrino e
vanno quindi controlliamo dalle camere
di sicurezza dove sono adesso non ci
sono più
no poi le imposte penso che ce la può
fare
penso che si sono mossi sì perché
o non ci sono più torno questo ancora
più affetto che televoto dov'è
se non so
potete cosa porta chiusa poi consumo sto
quasi per finire ai più io chiudevo da
spina luce dove sto numero di allora ok
non so chiuso e qui nello stage
però sarà dura
ok con te
l'importante che non vengano qua ok non
c'è nessuno si vuol 15 mia scelta ma
cosa succede se finisco le nere spegne
la luce e si aiuta un favore che
spuntano all'improvviso
non ce ne sono ancora guardiamo le
camere tutte con appositi energia prima
nota ancora per sempre almeno
poi dov'è l'orsacchiotto che dovrebbe
essere freddi sono più quindi vuol dire
che no non spegne la luce e poi vicino
[Musica]
ma sempre più questa notte sta
abbassando abbastanza tranquilla la pira
27 per cento
mi attaccherei più niente perché se
hanno già dato l'energia come non ce la
facciamo arrivare
il giorno dopo sentiamo se si sono
tumori si
arrivando a gaza è molto distante di
quanto penso che l'attesa di far
rilassare un pochettino e tipo ti tiene
in ansia però all'improvviso non erano
stati otterrà la volpe allora non
capisco bene come posso prevenire che
loro arrivino allora secondo me dove
dobbiamo sentire attentamente i rumori
perché prima che comparisse ci sono
stati dei rumori molto forte e magari
tempo a prendere le porte proporrei le
camere per capire dove sono il fatto che
io non so dove sono cioè non so se sono
vicino al bagno vicino ci dovrebbe
essere un popolo allora faccio lo stage
sono tutti qua per ora mi sembra che
siano tutti fa lo stesso 49 anno amantea
volte qua non c'è nessuno
a questo sono solo delle teste non lo so
vediamo qui anche qua non c'è nessuno ma
io dove sono però in questa mappa almeno
capisco se sono vicino a meno acqua c'è
sotto ok penso che per ora
è tutto ok
non si fa
quindi io devo cercare di capire quando
si stanno avvicinando alla mia stanza e
chiudere le porte prima che arrivino
escono proprio dove lo porta sì che
altri non hanno posto
[Musica]
all'anziano slim sta tornando di nuovo
nello spaventiamo per favore ok poi
senza tanta rabbia è sembrato normale
almeno ciò che ancora non so bisogna via
ma come si sono mosse con mente va beh
aspettiamo scorsa un bene i suoni dei
gioca un posto adesso così si spaventerà
il tour non consumare troppa energia in
quanto sento dei rumori
qui non si vede nulla questi sono certo
una super inquietanti che se non sapesse
sono infatti se sono gli animatronics
non sai qualcosa che salta su sezione
nella seconda notte forse non ci
arriveremo mai incassate una piazza se
volete anche la seconda parte ayew
eccolo stampa si ok ora capisco
finalmente quindi quando sono i fiori
dentro quando sono fa vicino dobbiamo
stare molto attenti però io sempre un
ovvio come si facciano venire
[Musica]
non massa non c'era nessuno ancora le
altre stanze proprio come si sposta vede
nessuno perché poi è un'altra stanza
vicino a noi a volte sentiti da subito
mi sembrava discapito dei rubati
il punto è fondato motivo improvviso
attenzione abbiamo sole al 62 per cento
ad essi non sono per cento
ho sentito la voce di qualcuno
però le camere vicino
sembra tutto ok mi guardano come se lo
vuole più vicina escono anche qui ma
queste sono dietro forza
mi sembra tutto regolare
[Musica]
vediamo di capire dove sono o non c'è
più nessuno
sono solo 11 sacchetto mentre due sono
scappati
vuol dire che so fare meglio
caro sono fra le tre sere 150 per cento
è già consumato un periodo no aspettiamo
di sentire qualche rumore se una
finestra di che fosse si devono adesso
il loro successo
non c'è niente
ho paura di sangiovese e non c'è nessuno
però è sentito tutto si sono dei passi e
private show
quattro sono già spariti sono già
spariti un po allora qua c'è ancora lo
stacchetto ma tutti gli altri non ci sto
questi non si capisce sono reali sono
solo le teste che sta vicino vicino ad
esperti e di
si spegne ad essere chiuso perché so che
arriverà prima o poi vabbè ho capito
poco si consuma energia solo quando
accendo vicino a noi questo lo porta che
sono certo e con la maledetta quando
accendi la luce prima di aprire la porta
del lecce era che paura è una paperella
non devo aprire la porta quando vengono
ora poi vedi sei andato di là
aspetta oppure che arrivi di guardare
camera
allora vuoi aprire la porta a me lo
porto di qua è sempre vita a un ritorna
basta regalato di mortificare e questo
deve cioè perché senza fede rumori
senza il profitto amici della natura
[Musica]
stanno facendo un sacco di rumore
nessuno e quindi procedere alla posta
affetti sono 35 ma non c'è nessuno credo
regioni con oltre di progetto cup a casa
noi perché non finisce la giornata alle
7 di bobo
dobbiamo cercare di finire ammazzato
[Musica]
così sono passato se conduzione ma mi sa
mai
non ci posso credere che siano fatte
anche io ci credo che ce l'hai fatto
spero che salvi la partita ok il mondo
gioco ma seconda notte
queste giappone è pronto
non si risparmia nessuno dovrebbe
rispondere
[Musica]
o meglio
sono solo alcune camere sono andata
allora traduciamo quello che ha detto ha
detto che
bisogna guardare gli angoli morti dove
le camere non prendono che si può fare
facilmente portando 13 ancora fatto la
luce no no io questa porta qualcuno ha
staccato la corrente come faccio ha
detto infatti alcune telecamere non
funzionano dove sono
saremo quindi da tempo qua c'è solo uno
stato bene cellino 32 si fa troppa paura
che un giorno un po difficile arrivarci
perotti albero 5 notti vero quello del
gioco non va bene è troppo inquietante
come appaiono all'improvviso se mi fa
continuare nella notte due pro life
fallo tu adesso io mi devo riprendere
seconda notte dai proviamo per l'ultima
volta
vediamo se ce la facciamo allora qua c'è
ma tutti ci sono tutti attori sono 34
non capisco non ho capito quello lì
nascosto dietro la tenda queer dinosauro
sauro scriveteci nei commenti quanti
sono questi animatronic penso che non
sarà molto tranquillo non sprecare
troppa in eroe mio consiglio diceva di
controllare comunque le camere perché
quando non
non lo controlli però un lungo tempo
loro si sistema di disabilità o si
stancano
poi anche detto se vedi lì animatronics
nelle camere vicino a te vuol dire che è
solo pochi secondi per reagire e
chiudere le porte infatti sei stata
brava la notte uno perché io avrei
lasciato aperto questi sembrano che ci
siano tutti e tre
[Musica]
chiede quindi vicino a te pare sicura
era lì vicino ma non so in quale porta
entrerà dovetti e proprio guardian con
noi per qua sotto a destra possiamo
aprire che paura
n'è andato lì in alto
ok allora si può riaprire la porta ma
meno che non sia proprio aspettava la
paura la vita ed anzi vedevo quella
camera riapro no ancora lì ovviamente
che c'è qualcosa non sprecare l'energia
energia caso di aprire perché dai voglio
capire bene e va bene per te qui non c'è
qui non c'è chi non se non è da nessuna
parte dietro la porta
cinese che erano qui a ben lontano da
controllate non ci sia qualcuno
nell'altra porta perché
non è questo lo possiamo aprire
beh aperta e chiusa e dovresti almeno
accendere la luce per vedere se c'è
qualcuno non c'è nessuno
vediamo le camere va bene questa lontana
solo uno c'è qualcuno qui doveri quindi
si sta avvicinando sta per avvicinarsi
alla porta a destra atene
no la sinistra pensano questa o quella
che io stimo tra le due non ce la faremo
mai a superare questo ancora non c'è
nessuno li vede che c'è qualcuno ha
visto che non a caso l'affare detto pure
mai stata la dire che si sta avvicinando
youtube fatto sì mi chiamo tutta
l'energia
abbiamo tutti paura o note basse tutti i
passi passati passi attiva 7
stanno arrivando lo so guarda
senti che stiamo facendo casino non sono
però non qui ma non poi la sera chiesa
finiamo l'energia stupiscono mi sa che
nessuno
quello che è stato preso nel dramma mia
che ne parla di cinema qualche parte si
resta titolo porta ha fatto è che stiamo
per finire l'energia se finiamo
l'energia però non si chiuse se lo portò
bene fantasmi sta per arrivare
[Musica]
che si sta per arrivare se vuoi 31
secondo forte lasciate un bel mi piace
su questo video raggiungere i 15 mila mi
piace faremo la seconda parte anche se
questo gioco vivete un'altra passetto
dopo
mammamia fateci sapere nei commenti a
quante notti siete riusciti ad arrivare
e ora vi lasciamo a quattro case lire su
militare per vedere i nostri altri video
kakà su quella delle preferite